m
le vernissage d'une exposition d'arts
plastiques réalisés par un groupe
d'enfants placés au groupement d'unité
territoriale du tampon est venu clôturer
cinq mois d'ateliers une action
collective menée par les travailleurs
sociaux du but du tampon qui a concerné
38 enfants 6 par an et 14 assistants
familiaux
une exposition de dessins sur le thème
de la découverte de l'afrique c'est un
vernissage c'est le rendu du travail qui
a été fait de ce travail collectif
mais que créations des enfants
création
d
du coup tu comment dire des assistants
des éducateurs des parents des familles
accueillantes et donc voilà vous savez
un très très bon résultat avec
un véritable vernissage jeudi mais avec
de très belles très belle sacs des
activités artistiques qui ont permis aux
éducateurs de sortir de leur pratique
quotidienne d'envisager différemment
leur mission pour les enfants ces
ateliers en favoriser l'expression et la
créativité de chacun
puis nous montrer qu'elle paris peuvent
avoir
c'est d'apporter un petit peu quelque
chose qui leur est intime quelque chose
qui relève du talent chez eux que chez
chacun d'eux et qui leur fait dépasser
un petit peu le
le statut d'enfant confie à l'aide
sociale à l'enfance
les découvriront demain ce qu'ils ont de
meilleur et de plus
à travers cette activité les enfants ben
s'exprime déjà travers les outils qu'on
met à leur disposition
et également les échanges qui peuvent
savoir avec les autres réseaux sociaux
et notamment les enfants
on nous faire des activités éducatives
s'est aussi dit fais ce diversifier
nos tâches
dans nos pratiques
les enfants et leurs familles
on a chaque fois donc pousser aussi
observer les enfants différemment en
spectacle de danses africaines préparé
par les enfants et de clôturer ce
vernissage